l'union européenne joue la carte de la
solidarité en grèce alors que des
milliers de migrants sont toujours
stoppés à la frontière gréco turque
les dirigeants européens se réunissaient
en urgence aujourd'hui au poste
frontalier de caste à nice la présidente
de l'union européenne
ursula von der leyen a tenu à affirmer
un soutien total de l'europe à la grèce
dépassé par ce conflit humanitaire les
autorités grecques font face à cette
difficile tâche qui consiste à contenir
cette situation je voudrais remercier
les gardes frontière et les gardes côtes
grecs
je voudrais remercier les civils les
agents et agentes de police et je
voudrais remercier frontex pour leur
action infatigable ex il est important
pour moi d'être ici avec vous
aujourd'hui et vous dire que
l'appréhension des grecs est aussi la
nôtre
cette frontière n'est pas seulement
grecque mais aussi européenne et à ce
titre je suis ici en tant qu'européenne
un soutien public et matérielles la
présidente de l'union européenne promet
une aide financière de 700 millions
d'euros à athènes afin de répondre aux
enjeux d'une nouvelle vague migratoire à
la demande de la grèce
l' agence européenne de surveillance des
frontières frontex s'est dite prête à
déployer une force rapide comprenant
notamment un navire de patrouille heures
deux hélicoptères et un avion sans
gardes frontières européens
supplémentaires seront déployés
s'ajoutant ou 530 déjà présents
concernés par la politique agressive de
recep tayyip erdogan en syrie la russie
souhaite également apporter son aide à
l'europe
nous comprenons pleinement la complexité
du problème des migrants pour l'union
européenne je l' ai déjà dit un dialogue
est en cours entre la fédération de
russie et la diplomatie européenne et
nous allons le poursuivre
de son côté la france par le biais du
ministre des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian condamne fermement le
comportement de la turquie
nous avons demandé le président de la
république au président poutine de faire
cesser cette offensive d'idlib d'en
revenir aux cadres de sotchi mais la
solidarité doit aller dans les deux sens
et l' usage par la turquie des migrants
comme moyen de pression et de chantage
sur l'europe est absolument inacceptable
pendant ce temps là des dizaines de
milliers de personnes attendent toujours
de savoir leur prochaine destination